charles payne host of making money with
charles payne on fox business
understands this he's been watching this
since the beginning and doing what we
cannot do which is assessing it as a
business play and we're happy to have
him join us now charles thanks so much
for coming on what do you make of this
you know tucker i wish i could go
through every one of those things you
talked about for instance the folks on
cnn i feel like they never been to a
garage sale i mean yeah he's negotiating
elon musk for this piece msnbc he's a
freeloader you got to be kidding me he's
got 99 000 employees and he's bringing
factories back to america
and so from a business perspective
you've got a guy who sold a business for
176 million dollars what did he do he
plowed every single nickel into two pipe
dreams one was called tesla one was
called spacex the very same people that
are saying he's unsophisticated today
are the same ones who said he couldn't
make it then well fast forward to his
wealth net worth being 276 billion
dollars right now and you know the
notion of free speech uh in america ever
becoming controversial and of itself
tells you we're in a dangerous place
someone talked about the quote-unquote
orange man let me tell you about the
orange man when president trump was
elected twitter stock was 16 a share
when president trump left office it was
77 a share and promptly went into free
fall this is a company that really has
shot themselves in the foot they are
losing big time they need fresh thinking
out there and elon musk is the right
medicine it's the right medicine from a
business perspective and it certainly is
the right medicine for the ethos for the
foundation that america was founded on
really quick do you think musk
understands what's about to happen to
him i mean they're going to try and
crush him for real
he does because everything he has done
tucker they have tried to crush him they
have tried to crush tesla at every turn
the white house hates tesla because it's
a non-union shop they have tried to beat
him down every single way they can he
knows the challenge by the way that's
why he made it 54-20 he gave him a shot
he knew they would make fun of it but
that's how elon musk operates he says
come at me baby come at me because he is
a winner and guess what they're all all
they have is opinions
if this works and twitter is opened up
to free speech and elon musk is still
standing a year from now it will be a
different country it will be a better
charles payne i appreciate you're coming
on tonight
yep i hope so thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight